to this um i guess new format for the
for the quantum colloquium so we are
going to start with a tutorial about
quantum chemistry
by brian uh gorman who is
um who is now a phd student here at
berkeley and uh
um yeah so uh
so brian just turning it over to you
great uh yeah thanks so much um so this
will be
a very short introduction to quantum
chemistry
aimed at computer sciences
so my primary goal will be to convey the
idea that
the main problem of quantum chemistry is
nothing more or less than
a very special case of local hamiltonian
and then i'll conclude by briefly
discussing some classical approaches
and their limitation
so the model of the physical world
that is relevant to chemistry is that we
have
some nuclei in space these point charges
surrounded by a cloud of electrons
and of course the nuclei are at some
level
quantum mechanical but they
are so much more massive than the
electrons that it's a very good and
common approximation
known as the born oppenheimer
approximation to treat them as classical
so we just treat them as fixed points in
space um
but the electrons on the other hand uh
we need to treat as quantum mechanical
in order for our calculations to match
what we see in the real world like there
are seem to be
inherently quantum dynamics in these
these molecules
and so what we'll do is we'll you know
fix the nuclei in space
we'll solve for the electronic ground
state
and we'll do this for you know many
different uh configurations of the
nuclei
and if we do this over you know a range
of of configurations
we can start to sketch out this energy
landscape
as a function of the nuclear coordinates
and this allows us to do chemistry
because
you know molecules are just the local
minima of
this uh energy landscape and if we
understand
this landscape then we understand you
know what molecules
exist and how they turn into each other
you know how chemical reactions take
place
um and so in order to do chemistry we
need to sketch out this landscape
but really the hard part is just finding
this electronic ground state at any
particular point in the landscape
and so after this live i'll exclusively
talk about that problem
and we'll fix the nuclei and we'll try
to find for the lowest energy states of
the electrons
but two things to note about this
problem
is first that you know we can move this
energy landscape
um up or down you know globally and it
doesn't change anything so if somehow
we had a method that was systematically
but consistently wrong by some fixed
additive amount
that would be fine you know all that
matters for chemistry is energy
differences not the absolute energies
and another thing to note is a comment
on how precisely we need to solve this
problem
so you'll often hear chemists talk about
uh chemical accuracy
uh and sometimes they'll mean you know
they'll quantify that by
referring to some absolute energy like a
millihar tree or something like that
but what they really mean is that you
know we can solve the
uh electronic ground state problem
sufficiently precisely
so that you know if we solve it a bunch
of times and sketch out an energy
landscape
that this energy landscape at least
qualitatively looks like it should
you know its features its local minima
its humps
um match those of the real world and and
if we understand you know
the the our computation of the energy
landscape then we understand
um you know the chemical dynamics of the
system
and another thing to note is that uh you
know we'll focus on the ground state
problem
but sometimes chemists are also
interested in you know closely related
problems like
other properties of the ground states or
even properties of
low-level exciting states low energy
excited states
and so we we fix the nuclear coordinates
and we ask
what is the lowest energy this energy
function has
two components one is completely
independent of the electronic state so
it's just the interaction
of these positively charged nuclei
interacting with each other
uh but because we're fixing the nuclei
this is a constant
uh and going forward we'll just
completely neglect it you know it
doesn't change
with respect to the things that we're
optimizing over
and what we really care about is again
this uh lowest energy electronic state
um and the you know this expression on
the bottom
should not yet make sense um but over
the next 10 to 15 minutes
you know i'll build up and return to
this in a way that hopefully will make
sense
so before talking about uh you know the
hamiltonian itself
i'd like to spend a little bit of time
talking about just what i mean by the
state of electrons
because there are some slight
differences between the states of
electrons and say the states of qubits
so things are quite simple if we just
have a
single electron we have this wave
function in in real space
uh it's normalized uh you know the
square of its magnitude or over some
region of space
gives the probability that an electron
is in that space
that region but
this wave function is a continuum object
and we want to compute things and so we
need to
discretize the the system in some way
and the way that we do this is by
choosing uh some finite
basis of single particle orbitals uh in
which we can at least
approximately represent this state
and so once we've done that you know
we're approximating this um
wave function in real space but on our
computers it just looks like a q-tip
right we have some
n amplitudes um that that represent our
our wave function within this single
particle basis
and but ultimately we want to choose a
good
basis we'll want to choose a basis
function
a set of basis functions that minimize
what's called the basis set error
the which is the difference in energy
between the true ground state energy
and the lowest energy of the states
within the space spanned by
our basis
and so things get a little more
interesting when we move to two
electrons
so again we start with some wave
function of two particles in real space
it's normalized we discretize it in some
way
using some finite basis and again you
know on our computers this just looks
like a pair of q-dits
um but this is where you know physics
comes into play
these electrons are identical or
indistinguishable indistinguishable
uh which means that uh the wave function
needs to be symmetric or anti-symmetric
and in particular electrons are fermions
which means that the wave function needs
to be antisymmetric
so operationally this means that you
know we need to restrict our attention
to states that are minus one eigenvalues
um
sorry uh minus one eigenvectors of the
the swap operator
and so you know instead of considering
you know all states of these q
two q dits and we need to restrict our
attention to this anti-symmetric
statement which is much smaller
uh i mean it's still you know
combinatorially large but but it's not
uh
the full state of two qubits um and in
particular
one implication of this
anti-symmetrization
is what's called the poly exclusion
principle the idea that
two fermions two electrons cannot occupy
the same state
so for example here if p is equal to q
these two things cancel out and so
the only uh non-trivial parts of this
this superposition
are those where the electrons are in
distinct states
um and because of that you know there's
this alternative way of looking at the
states of these two particles
where instead of saying you know this
electron is here and that electron is
there
we look at the possible places that it
can be the possible states that it can
be in
and we just say how many electrons are
in those states
and because these are fermions that
number is just zero or one
and so in this occupation representation
also known as the foc basis
uh we can represent um our basis states
by simply bit strings let's say you know
whether or not uh each orbital is
occupied by an electron
and so for concreteness you know suppose
we had uh two electrons and four
orbitals
you know we have these equivalent
particle and occupation representations
and you know an arbitrary states of
these two electrons in these four
orbitals
is you know spanned by these six states
rather than say the sixteen states of uh
two qubits
uh and of course you know we want to
treat systems that have many more than
two
electrons uh and so what does this look
like for you know an arbitrary number of
electrons
uh so we start with uh you know what
look like cubits
but now again we restrict our attention
to uh the anti-symmetric subspace
um you know the minus one eigenspace of
every pairwise swap operator
and again we have these two different
ways of representing states
um so one is you know by sets of
distinct orbitals
and the the anti-symmetric uh summation
over them
and there's a way of writing uh this
expression uh in the second to last line
such that it literally is the
determinant of a particular matrix
and so often we'll refer to um you know
this set of orbitals as a determinant
which has this uh alternative
representation uh by a bit string that
just says you know
where the zero or one indicates which
orbitals are in the
determinant or not
and so those are ways of representing
states we also need to represent
operators
and in the occupation basis we do this
by
uh with what's called the annihilation
and creation operators
so all these do is you know act on
states
with uh an electron in a particular
orbital
and remove it so this is the
annihilation operator and the creation
operator acts on a states uh without an
electron in a particular orbital
and puts one there and these are
elementary operators
in the sense that uh an arbitrary
operator on these states can be
expressed as some combination of these
uh sort of an analogy with uh you know
the poly operators for for qubits
and there's a special combination of
these called the number operator
that just tells us whether or not
there's an electron in a particular
orbital
uh and so these are our quantum
operators you know they do not commute
and in fact you know certain pairs of
them anti-communes um
and the useful thing about these
operators is that
we've moved the anti-symmetrization from
the being encoded in the state to be
encoded in the operators
and so now we can you know start to talk
about what is what is the hamiltonian
that we care about
um so at least the part that depends on
the electronic state has uh three
components
one is the kinetic energy these
electrons are particles moving around in
space and there's an energy associated
with that
and the other two parts are simply the
coulomb or electromagnetic interactions
so there's
an interaction between the electrons and
the nuclei
uh this zi is just the charge of the
nuclei
uh and you know these are oppositely
charged particles so this is you know
contributes negative energy and then
there's the interaction of the electrons
with themselves
and and they're both positively charged
and so this is a repulsive interaction
you know they want to move away from
each other
uh and so this is you know this captures
at a high level you know the
the competing parts of the hamiltonian
you know we have these
centers of atoms in space the electrons
are attracted to them
but they're also repelled by each other
and so you know the
true ground states you know tries to
find this balance between being
the electrons being near the nuclei and
also away from each other
and so you know viewed as a formal
computational problem
an instance of this hamiltonian is
specified by a few
you know simple parameters where the
nuclei are and what their charges are
and the number of electrons and that's
it
could i ask which parts of these
hamiltonians commute and which parts
don't commute with each other
um
the these two parts don't commute
yeah um i mean this is like this is
uh so this is just the this nabla is
like a derivative operator
um and so you know these parts are just
diagonal
in you know some continuum position
basis um
and the the kinetic energy operator is
not
yeah um so i mean like very very
informally this is sort of like
uh an x and z situation
um yeah it's position and momentum yeah
and that's actually uh maybe i shouldn't
get too much into this but uh
in the you know some quantum algorithms
they exploit this they'll like switch
bases
where um part of the hamiltonian is
diagonal
and they'll rotate to a different basis
in which the the rest of it
is diagonal um
so yeah so this is the hamiltonian you
know in the continuum
uh and you know again we discretize we
choose some
um basis of single electron orbitals
uh and within these orbitals uh we get
these coefficients of the hamiltonian um
that are just these integrals
over these physical energy operators
and so you know often chemists will
treat these coefficients as
the um the instance is the problem
they're trying to solve
but really they're completely determined
by a much smaller amount of information
and so in the particle representation
the particle basis
this electronic structure hamiltonian
literally is a two local hamiltonian
you know we have these one local kinetic
and external potential
terms and we have this two local um
you know electron electron interaction
and you know one of the special things
about
the hamiltonian in this representation
is that all of these terms are identical
you know there's a single kinetic
there's a single one local kinetic
energy operator that acts identically on
all of the coupons qubits
um or q-tip sorry uh and and same for
the the external potential
and also you know not only is there one
that's repeated throughout it has a lot
of
x uh it has a lot of internal structure
uh because
you know its coefficients come from
these integrals over particular
operators
and so in this representation the goal
is to find the um
lowest energy anti-symmetric state um
and this may be you know a bit of a
departure from
traditional quantum hamiltonian
complexity this restriction to
anti-symmetric states
but there's this alternative
representation
in the occupation basis where we
no longer have to explicitly restrict
our attention to
the anti-symmetric subspace because it's
sort of baked into
the formalism by construction uh and so
here instead of having uh
you know a two local hamiltonian we have
what's called
um one body and two body operators so
this one body operators
move you know the terms of this one body
operator move
a single electron from one place to
another
and the the two body terms move a pair
of electrons from
you know a pair of orbitals to another
pair of orbitals
and you know these coefficients are not
completely arbitrary
um you know as i showed a slide or two
ago they're completely determined by
these integrals over these physical
energy functions given the the single
particle orbitals
and so there's a lot of structure in the
these coefficients that can be exploited
both by
uh classical and quantum algorithms
uh and yet despite you know how
specific and special does this local
hamiltonian is
still is qma heart um and i
you know i'll point you to an archive
that my collaborators i
just put on the archive that goes into
the details of you what exactly i mean
by this statement
and so this is uh you know about as much
as i'll say about the hamiltonian
uh and now we can start to talk about
the
uh how to solve it and the difficulties
they're in
so can i ask ask her something
so this this hap is on the hemi
the hamiltonian in this formalism is is
four local
right in this letter one yeah yeah
um yeah so strictly speaking this is
like you know a quartet polynomial
um but uh it's
um it's just you need to
you know the the important thing is um
so all of these physical hamiltonians
are number preserving
you know they have a you know the terms
have an equal number of
uh creation and annihilation operators
um right because this is you know
a thing that is physically preserved in
the system particles don't just
appear out of nowhere or disappear uh
and so you know really there are four
things here
but what really matters is that there's
two of each um
yeah and so you know i should
i you know my sense is that you should
really think of this as a two local
operator
um it's just that in this representation
that corresponds to having four things
and two of each type
so are these coefficients easy to
compute the hpq and
um yeah so so they're they're easy to
compute
well actually so that depends um on the
choice of the
orbitals so um
you know these are the coefficients
these are the um
things that need to be computed um
and this is why chemists often choose
gaussian basis sets because if these
orbitals are gaussians then these things
are easier to compute
and for other choices of orbitals they
are less easy to compute and here
the um you know for a certain
non-gaussian choice of orbitals they may
be
um not hard to compute in the sense that
we could do it polynomially
uh but there may in certain cases be
like
thousands of these um and so you know
easy and hardness
in that case is uh you know a matter of
degrees of polynomials and not
necessarily
um polynomials versus uh polynomial
versus exponential um but yeah so so
and then there's a trade-off between um
you know storing it and computing it on
the fly you know this is a question both
in classical and quantum
computation and you know these really
large
large-scale
implementations you know balance this in
some way
depending on the the resources and the
particular system
okay so in your qma hardness result uh
you don't have to feed this hpq as input
like you can probably
yeah so it's basically um you specify
the orbitals
um and then imply that those imply the
coefficients
uh and that's actually the um the
the progress that we made over previous
work so it was known that um
if you have a a generic hamiltonian that
looks like this
and you can just arbitrarily set the
coefficients uh it was previously known
that that was qma hard but what we
showed is that
if you just specify the orbitals and use
the coefficients implied by those
orbitals
then that that is qma hard without
a magnetic field that a previous
construction used
um there's a question on the chat do you
want to take it now
uh sure yeah um
maybe maybe we should keep going because
we have only eight minutes so i don't
know if you want to
how much time you have brian yeah yeah
uh
so i maybe a few more minutes um
so yeah let me just quickly answer those
two questions um this should be simple
uh so we don't uh you know i've stopped
talking about
the nuclear nuclear interactions because
they're constant
so yeah so we need to add them in when
we're comparing different nuclear
configurations
but for a fixed nuclear configuration
when we're optimizing over the
electronics
we don't need to always consider it and
add it back in
and then the other thing is spin so one
thing i have not mentioned anything
about
is that uh you know electrons are
fermions because they're spin half
and so when you know whenever i talk
about
this orbital basis uh they come in pairs
where there's a spatial component
uh and a spin up and a spin down
component
um yeah so let me let me keep going
uh so yeah classical approaches
um it should be no surprise that um
we this quantum hamiltonian can have
very entangled ground states
um that may be hard to represent on a
classical computer let alone find
uh and so one common approach is to
um you know instead of optimizing over
all electronic states
optimize over you know a smaller class
of states that we can
efficiently represent and manipulate in
particular
the the hartree fox states is the best
so-called
single determinant so we pick some set
of you know orthogonal distinct
uh single particle um orbitals
and the hartree fox state is you know
the best one of those it's the
anti-symmetrized product of these
orbitals uh and so
one way of thinking about hartree fock
is that it's a sort of
fermionic analog of matrix products and
serves many of the same roles
uh and to find this heartrefox states uh
you know we iteratively solve
the the set of coupled equations that
consider the effects of the electrons on
each other
but only in some average way and so the
end result of these hartroot fog
calculations
is a sort of mean field approximation
and for many systems of interest uh this
gets us very far you know it gets us
ninety percent of the way there
but they're often you know we often need
to go further we need a more precise
answer
and so there's a family of methods
called configuration interaction
um that looks at not just the heart rate
fox state but states that are nearby it
in some sense
so without loss of generality we can
write the heartry fox states you know in
this simple way
and then we can start asking about we
can optimize over states that are near
the hartree fox state
um so we have single excitations doubles
triples and so on
these are like the number of hops away
uh and we can keep going
and then if we keep going uh and place
no restriction on the
you know distance from the heartrate fox
states in a way
we get to what's called full
configuration interaction or full ci
which is exact in the the basis set
and it's sort of like the gold standard
of these types of calculations it allows
us to you know
benchmark and verify other approximation
methods
but it's exponential and so it quickly
becomes
infeasible for even moderately sized
systems
uh and there are other ways of going
beyond hartree focus
different ways of choosing the limited
number of determinants to optimize over
and then the last thing i'll talk about
is so-called density functional theory
or dft and the idea here is that instead
of thinking directly in terms of the
wave function
you know we'll consider the electron
density which is just tells us you know
how many fractional electrons are at
each point in space
and the basis of dft is that there
exists a so-called universal functional
that takes in this electron density and
tells us the expectation value
of the hamiltonian under the wave
function that that
electron density corresponds to and this
is
universal in the sense that you know
this tnu this kinetic
energy operator and the electron
electron interaction operator
are instance independent you know they
exist for just whenever we have
electrons in space
these operators are there and then the
instance specific part this external
potential
that's easy to calculate given the
electron density it's just a simple
integral
um and so this is very nice in theory um
but the this universe the this proof
that the the universal functional exists
is non-constructive um and you know
there's a sense in which uh you know
it's provably hard to even compute this
functional
and so uh in practice what people do is
try to compute um
approximations to this functional um and
sometimes they work great and sometimes
they don't
and so to conclude you know the the like
i said
the the point i was trying to convey is
that you know the main problem of
quantum chemistry is is just a
particular type of electronic
uh structure hamiltonian um and
at least classically it's very hard to
to do to solve
and you know in the worst case it may be
hard for uh
quantum computers as well um but there's
hope and
expectation that uh for at least a lot
of the instances that we care about
you know quantum computers can help us
go well beyond what we can do
classically
and in a few minutes uh matthias will
tell us you know how and why
that's the case um great thanks uh
thanks brian uh quick question uh can
you can you address this
uh say a little bit about what it means
to compute something to chemical
accuracy
um yeah so the
um there's sort of like two two answers
one is um that
uh you know it's often just like
it'll be like one millihard tree it's
like these are
you know this hamiltonian is in physical
units and it'll just be you know you
need to be within
this particular amount um
and you know sometimes it's just a
matter of doing a little bit better than
uh
the last calculation um but but really
what what it means is that
um you know the chemistry what what is
if the dynamics of the system really
depend on this
energy landscape and so chemical
accuracy
just means that the energy landscape
looks like it should
you know if uh you know a certain bond
exists then it's you know
captured by the energy landscape um
and so you know there are examples where
you know the easiest
chemical systems to think about are just
these diatomic molecules
um where the only configuration
parameter is the
a single internuclear distance um and
the question is like do
these two atoms bond or not uh and so in
that case
uh you know chemical accuracy means that
uh
you know if there's a bond then we see
it and if there's not a bot we don't see
it
um and then you know that that's a
simple example you know there are
much larger molecules are much more
complicated but
yeah morally it's uh do our answers
qualitatively match
empirical data that that's what uh
chemical accuracy needs
um and then like translating that into
like you know
inverse poly or something like that
it's a little hard because chemists
typically don't think in terms of you
know
infinite family of instances it's like
here's a protein or here's an enzyme
i need this amount of accuracy so
there's no sense of real
scaling with system size or something
like that because there's only one
system
[Music]
i think they are um we're now at the
you know time for um
to to transition to the colloquium so
let's see if um
if matthias says brian could you could
you stop sharing your screen oh yeah